this business is up and down and there's
so many times where do you think
something's going to go through and then
the rug gets pulled out from under you
so in a broad sense how do you turn a
bad situation situation into a good one
and you capitalize on something that was
sort of a missed opportunity and then by
another way with it okay I would want to
answer that when with a broader stroke
to is that number one I think it ties
down to two who you are because if
you're as a person you're always looking
at the bright side looking at the glass
half full you're in whatever thing life
throws at you you could make lemonade
out of lemons or coconut water from
because that's the aim thing right now
you know in the Philippines kid you not
we're throwing coconut water away
because for us it's a waste product
while here it's 325 f word dollars for
small bottle if I knew that oh my god I
should have been sitting on a coconut
gold mine does that sound right yeah so
it's how you look at it if you're
already you know a negative person a
bitter person life would throw you the
biggest opportunity of all and hit you
like and you don't even know it it
creates this huge crater around you and
you don't even know it and it's sad
because there are people like that so
hopefully or not but then and even if
you are really just look at the bright
side because I do tend to believe there
are a lot of poor stores really really
really real Horrors in life and yet if
you take the bright side of things
because I have a colleague at work and
she told me she was listening to a video
on youtube and they were interviewing
100 year old woman and through the
Holocaust
and she survived all that to be a
hundred years old and she was laughing
and she was smiling and they said what's
your secret with all those Horrors going
and she said oh I'm am simple I don't
hold a grudge and I look at the best
things in life I don't deny I don't
discount the hurt I don't say that was
nothing but then I don't capitalize on
it I don't make it larger that it is and
to think it's already huge technical of
course but I don't dwell on it I just
move on and I just smile so with that
said uh yeah life opportunities people
anything you know they could throw
something at you but yeah if you'd have
that I'll take that turn this I'll turn
this around and make the most of it
because again you just don't know what
you think maybe such a negative a drain
on your time your effort your money and
you're already better and you're angry
and all that then you just make enemies
and not only but just you yourself
stress is not healthy anger is not
healthy you're just burning yourself up
while the other person is just thinking
what you'll have for breakfast well here
you are seething with with anger and
bitterness just let it go and
capitalized and and see how you could
turn it around because if you have that
attitude you'll be surprised everything
is always a blessing in disguise no
matter how bad that disguise use it
looks to you at that point but if you
look at the bigger picture and what I
said about everything falls in a circle
and everything actually works out for
the good you'll be surprised oh my god
if I was not here because of that
experience this would not have happened
and you'll be like look back in your
life like wow at that time it was really
hard it was really difficult to accept
like like nobody supported my film my my
Kickstarter campaign failed I got zero
and all I was asking for was a thousand
bucks but get if you look at it and you
learn from it and you don't take it as a
negative it was a negative event but
it's your attitude that's not negative
because the event you cannot control
it's your attitude but you can and if
you always look at the bright side and
be positive every negative event will
turn into positive so that's how I look
at it and in time you'll always proved
that to be correct and in my life it is
so it might take time I mean might take
years my table tomorrow nobody knows but
it's a guarantee that once you look at
the bright side of things things always
work out so so with that said just just
go with it just know how to roll with
the punches take a deep breath because
if it depends on what happens sometimes
you need to step back and think but then
when you're here you're clear and you
could really think well and no emotion
and you can just say hey you know it
happens to the best of them and I'll
just take it as it comes and i'll still
be professional about it I'll you know
I'll still have this attitude of
graciousness of humility and you're
appreciating everything even though it
really sucks you'll be surprised it
really really turns around it may be so
another event it could be another person
could just be anything and then just let
it happen I'm a firm believer like
serendipity sometimes it's like wow how
did that happen we just don't know you
put it on YouTube you don't know who's
watching it you put your best foot
forward it may be a negative in a sense
that you know I had to spend this and I
don't really have the money so that's a
negative or and you know my wife my
parents said maybe this is not really
great for me but hey I wanted to stand
up so and there's some open my hand John
is a physician going to an open mic was
great he was discovered now he's a star
movie star TV star I mean he's a
position so I mean who knew right so
always turn whatever it is negative into
a positive and just do your thing if
you're passionate for it if you love
doing it whatever life or other people
throw at you you'll always be in the
upright because you know what you want
you know you right if you're solid a
solid character you're strong enough and
you know what you want and you just keep
your eye on the ball
nobody could face that nobody could
throw you around so true negative events
negative people if you stand strong and
you have that attitude of like I'm
thankful I'm learning I want to learn I
want absorbs again everybody has to
start somewhere nobody's perfect so you
have to start somewhere if you have that
attitude of like I'm a sponge and I just
want to learn whether it's good or bad
even if it's the worst thing ever you
learn something if you're just hoping
you know be open that's that's I think a
lot of times a lot of people are so
closed-minded oh no this is the way to
do it why not this way thinking outside
the box and not only outside multiple
really outside everything else and just
be open and just me like to life to
experience you'll be surprised what was
a negative experience or you think a
missed opportunity maybe the best
opportunity ever you know in the world
so you know
you